No,
you're welcome to toxic Google.
I,
Kevin Hallock,
I'm going to be your host for today.
I'd like to welcome the cast and creative crew,
uh,
from big hero six.
It's so we have Chris Williams and don hall directors,
Ryan Potter,
Herro,
Jamie Chung,
Gogo to Manco,
Jansen's Rodriguez,
honey lemon,
and Roy kindly producer.
Hey guys.
Hi.
Was the fallout boyfriend was that marketing was just a suggestion from our
music department and you know,
we met him and they're like super cool and love.
Uh,
they love Disney and I love comic books a lot too.
So they were like the perfect choice.
No,
it's a,
it's a great film.
Now how many of you in the room saw the film last night and we showed it?
It was,
it was great.
We did a screening for the Google people.
People loved it.
Families loved it.
You know,
the theater was packed.
It was,
it was a beautiful,
beautiful film.
So,
and Don,
you were on it from the very beginning,
right after your pitch.
Three and a half years ago.
I was finishing up Winnie the Pooh and,
uh,
um,
I just talked to John about what my next thing would be.
And,
and as a kid,
I loved Disney animation.
I love marvel comics.
And,
and we had just purchased marvel.
Disney hadn't.
So I pitched that to John and he got really excited and said,
go find something,
go.
Um,
and I did a lot of research and found big hero six and,
and it felt like there were kind of the perfect choice for us.
I mean it's a very obscure title in the marvel sort of Pantheon,
but uh,
which actually ended up benefiting us I think a little bit.
But I'd love the characters.
I love the,
you know,
the,
the whole thing was very light and on light on his feet.
And the thing is like a love letter to sort of Japanese pop culture.
And we also saw that there could be an emotional story there too.
So head kind of all the elements we were looking for.
No,
absolutely.
And John Lasseter,
and he's always got his radar up for people's passions.
And when he sensed how excited don was about the idea of pursuing a marvel
property,
he really,
he really got behind them.
Great.
And then Roy,
when did you come onto the project?
I get mine with a project about a year ago and basically we kind of wrapped
everything up in terms of pulling together the story was,
or it was a long process and literally we,
we finished the film about 15 days ago.
Gosh.
And it's pretty mad on it,
man.
We finished the story process probably sometime in August,
so it was,
uh,
it was a,
it was a nice one.
Okay.
And Ryan,
our hero of the story,
uh,
I came on about a year and six months ago.
Okay.
Um,
it's the first voice acting role,
right?
This is my first voice acting role.
Yeah.
And um,
it's funny because the most,
the,
like the last recording session was maybe a month ago that we had.
Yeah.
So that's the story process of Disney,
right?
Yeah.
It's really just figuring out the story.
Always changing.
Always kind of literally.
And last year.
Yeah,
last year has a phrase he says our films are never finished there.
Just released.
We can go back.
That's right.
You guys,
you guys came on.
At what point in the filming?
I believe I auditioned last November.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Wow.
So I can't believe it's gone by so quick.
Right?
Yeah.
And you mostly live action cause you started off kind of your big kind of hit
was entourage really.
And then you kind of came on with last stand and identity theft in hours and you
work with this incredible people and teams and then you come into Disney and do
this.
His voice acting role.
So what was that like in terms of doing the voice as opposed to acting in front
of live real actors?
See I've always been a Disney fan,
so they did me a huge favor this job because you're welcome.
Thank you.
Okay,
well I heard fun fact.
I hear that you were on an all girls robotics team in high school and you're a
self proclaimed nerd.
Yes,
we have to talk about this.
Yes.
I was on a robotics team and I did basically robot wars and I was a welder and I
gave the robot commands.
Um,
I really wasn't into the physics aspect of it,
but um,
or a driver,
I don't drive in real life.
So,
um,
they didn't give me the robot,
to take care of,
but it was so much fun.
It was just the coolest thing I've ever done.
So then what,
what,
what was the transitioned into acting then?
I don't know how it translates.
I don't know what the similarities are.
I guess it's having an idea and being able to express it or execute it.
Um,
it was just really cool to just think of something and be able to create it and
make it actually tangible.
So,
um,
I had the best time.
I kind of love seeing the boys' faces when an all girls robotics team just would
walk up and they wouldn't think that we were so bad ass,
but we were,
did you guys know this before?
I didn't.
I mean,
it came,
I mean we'd,
I think we'd,
she already had the part and then we'll just talk and she's like,
Oh yeah,
I was on the all girl in this room about it.
And then they'd be like,
what's that?
Oh,
because I actually met on a research trip,
um,
uh,
back east at Carnegie Mellon.
I met the girls of steel,
which was a high school all girls robotics team in there.
Their logo was like Rosie the riveter with like cyborg arm.
That was really cool.
Um,
and again,
I was just struck by their spirit and,
uh,
and a lot of that,
you know,
we tried to get into the characters of honey lemon and Gogo,
just that idea of this can do,
they're all makers.
They're all scientific,
they're all super smart and enthusiastic and that really influenced those two
characters.
Okay.
Jamie,
so you're a San Francisco native?
Yes,
I am.
Well,
how,
so you're from here.
So what part of San Francisco?
Uh,
born and raised in Westwood Park,
like right by monitoring Miramar.
So it was a very,
was interesting cause it,
this is a beautiful,
beautiful film and you really captured the city and and it's an incredible,
was it cool kind of seeing San Francisco in an animal?
I mean to be honest,
I didn't really know how the world was going to look like and right away it's so
recognizable.
You know all the,
all the light,
all the great land marks are there.
So like the TRANSAMERICA building and the Golden Gate Bridge
and,
and market street.
It's,
it's really surreal because you don't get that feeling when you're in the
recording booth.
Want to talk about that because it was,
it's a beautiful,
beautiful film.
It's really,
it looks like you basically took the footprint of San Francisco and then you
just added all the aesthetics of Tokyo and just,
it's gorgeous stuff.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it was a,
yeah,
we started with basically a computer model of San Francisco.
You said we all,
we started with sort of the baseline,
the geography or,
and geographically it was always going to be San Francisco.
So we spent a lot of time in Tokyo doing research trips as well and,
and just try to get as much of that in there.
And we were just in Japan like a week ago for the world premiere.
We had a lot of Japanese press coming up to us and saying how,
uh,
they loved the film and they loved how authentic it felt down to little details.
Like,
you know,
we would,
they would put their empty recyclables in these milk crates and put them in
alleys.
Well we have that in a lot of shots in the film,
which I,
we didn't even know.
We didn't have to ask our production designer to do it.
They just did it.
But they were so appreciative of those little details like that because it just
made them feel like we did our homework.
You know,
we have,
we would love to take root.
Yeah,
exactly.
Hall Felix and Scott.
What?
Nabi.
Yeah.
Uh,
our production designer and art director,
they,
well,
Scott was kind of a secret weapon.
Yeah.
Cause Scott grew up in San Francisco and is Japanese American and he spent his
summers in Japan.
So it was like having this double threat.
I
mean,
yeah and I,
I've only been here three years in San Francisco and just even just the feel of
just the weather and the fog and the mist and the lighting,
like everything is very,
very specific.
In San Francisco we were,
uh,
we were tried very hard to capture the lighting because way it was important to
Jon laster.
Cause when we first pitched this idea it's like you've got to go up and you got
to study the light because the light in San Francisco is like no other place.
So we did send a team up here and,
and they were on,
you know,
rooftops of buildings taking like the time lapse photos of the light,
all through the day.
And we use that a lot in the film.
Even the placement of the sun and the sky is accurate to San Francisco depending
on the time of day of the scene.
Like they go really deep.
And it's important to make note of this be because before we tried to construct
the story,
we try to,
we build the world.
And because the story is something that over the course of the years of
production is going to evolve quite a bit.
We work in a very iterative way.
The story is always going to going to change,
but you're kind of stuck with the world Ukraine.
So before we do that,
we go back and do tons and tons of research and,
and our art direction,
our director of production design and really immerse themselves in,
in this world.
And they sketch a lot and they,
and they take pictures and they really immerse themselves.
And that's why it feels so complete.
And it feels like the world has a history to it.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
I mean,
even this post,
so we have kind of sitting back there,
you know,
production to Miguel around,
but it's just a beautiful,
just sunset with Baymax and,
and a here and your character is an awesome seeing with Bay Max where you guys
are flying around in the city and kind of testing them out.
And there's a,
there's a beautiful little part in there.
It's not an acting on your part.
I know it's an anime,
but it's a beautiful little scene with hero where it's your catch,
your reflection and the,
you know,
in the building.
So it's a little subtle but it's amazing moment for the character to just of be
like,
oh this is awesome when opened.
I'm doing,
it's,
it's funny you say that because that's something that I do in my everyday life
and I'm trying to find out which of the animators put that in there cause they
watch,
you know,
hours and hours of,
of me in the booth and then Washington,
you know,
they wash my face and when my body does and um,
w when I,
when I look at something and I think it's cool or I think it's entertaining or
funny,
I almost do this laugh to myself.
It's like,
Huh,
I do that.
And when does it twice in the film he does it when he's on the back of Tadashi,
his moped,
he,
you know,
they hit up and then he's looking next to like the glass and he sees himself,
he does a laugh.
And then that scene parallels with the,
for the first flight scene where he's on the back of Baymax and he's going
around the city and he sees himself in the mirror again,
well in the glass.
And it was just so bizarre watching the film when those two things,
I missed the first one the first time around,
but when I saw the one where he's on the back of Baymax blew my mind.
Cause there's some,
some animator saw me do that in the booth and put it into the film.
Yeah,
yeah.
No it's,
it's such a cool part.
Oh sorry.
That's the first time I cried.
We're not the last 103 d glasses.
Yes.
No,
it's,
it's such an
terrible scene.
It just kind of gets to the actual,
it makes these characters alive and their actual human beings,
you know,
they're not computer or data,
they're actual human beings and seeing that little moment he could just be
flying around,
but he's actually seeing how cool it is.
Just the,
you know,
a complete teenager thing
to do a total testament to our animators.
So we've got the greatest animation team.
I think in the business right now who,
who are,
are able,
you know,
to take human characters and make them come alive.
I mean,
oftentimes I'll be talking to people and they'll say,
you know,
I forgot I was watching an animated film.
And you know,
it's not photo real.
It's not,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's totally exaggerated in the way a,
an animated film should be.
Yeah.
But you,
you,
you emotionally and fall in love with these characters and you just go with it.
And you know,
and Ford,
those little moments of,
of spontaneity,
we really rely on big moments.
We really rely on these guys relying on past because the way animation works,
it's so everything is so meticulously planned.
Everything you see on the screen,
every little crack in the sidewalk is a choice that somebody made.
Um,
and so the one place where we can find spontaneity is in the recording booth and
with these guys and they still inhabited the characters and,
and,
and brought them to life.
And so we're,
we're,
we're very,
very grateful.
Full to you guys.
Thank you.
Yeah.
The Janssen.
Jimmy,
that must have been actually interesting too cause you watch yourself on screen
live action films and you obviously see yourself but now you're seeing these
characters up on screen.
So did you see any little bits that the animators took out from you guys?
I mean they got the narrowed aspect,
right?
The first thing was like I totally hear it out in the room and they acted a fool
for the new guy or like four hours and I saw some of the cooking is and you know
the lip biting thing and just the,
the,
the mad scientist that we didn't in room.
They captured that.
Okay.
We needed to give genesis lots of room there.
We move things out of the way ball very.
I'm very active there.
Were any of you guys together
during the recording process?
No,
not at all.
We met less than a month ago.
Oh my gosh.
For the first time at a cast dinner.
It's hard to do.
Um,
the APP,
just because everybody's schedules and all in our production schedule is in a
perfect world.
It'd be awesome though.
I mean to get everybody in and record at the same time.
I worked with,
uh,
my Rudolph who voices and cast for about 20 minutes.
I thought that was about it.
Um,
but um,
yeah,
I mean,
it,
it's,
it was fun.
It was fun being able to work with another actor,
but with,
with voiceover,
I think,
I think what's so amazing about it is it's because it's just yourself.
It's,
you have so much freedom to play around because usually in live action you're
worried about someone maybe messing up align or I watch my body looked like on
camera.
Well,
you know,
you have all these things to worry about with voice.
It's just,
it's,
it's simply your voice so you can,
you run around the room,
you can do cartwheels as long as you're,
you know,
the voice matches is all that.
Yeah.
And to expand on that,
I feel like with,
you know,
the difference between doing a live action film and doing an animation film is
you have the luxury of time.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
John's been with this project for for many,
many years and for them to continue,
leap,
protect,
uh,
you know,
perfected.
And same thing with the character is,
you know,
we had that luxury.
No,
I think that's a great thing about Disney and you know,
picks her up as a,
to where you guys,
you guys want stunned cats.
It's not like you're like,
get Brad Pitt,
look at Tom Cruise and they're,
it's,
you guys find the perfect people because you guys just blend perfectly in with
these characters.
You know,
when you,
again,
I think goes to the realism of the character who you really believe these
characters are alive but hiding that boys in the character and they are,
you are hero and you are go,
go.
You know,
it's,
it's incredible.
I really feel that way pretty early on in the process.
It became impossible to imagine anyone else playing these characters.
They're just really inhabited them.
And,
and uh,
yeah,
I have to remember these,
these guys have to conjure up everything.
They don't have a costume.
They don't have a set,
they don't have the other actors,
uh,
to bounce off of.
And,
and if it was a live action thing,
you would probably come to the,
to the set to do one scene that day.
Uh,
whereas we have them race from scene to scene to scene in the course of one
recording session,
the whole movie basically.
Yeah.
So it might be a comedic scene followed by a very emotional scene with,
with,
with great tragedy and they're forced to sort of,
to sort of nimbly sort of shift from one thing to another.
And I'm always really amazed and we're all exhausted by the end of each
recording session.
No,
I bet.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's an incredible film really about a boy really coming of age and these
teenagers and these college students really coming of age.
And there's this beautiful,
really interesting part,
which I've never really done seen,
done in animation before.
Where am I going to spoil it for people who haven't seen the movie,
but there's a part where a particular character,
just because it does a complete one 80,
you know,
and it's completely changes.
And I haven't seen that before,
especially from,
you know,
it definitely one of the main characters and it's,
it's so interesting cause it's,
it's a real emotion,
right?
Like I think it's something that's very specific to someone who is young who
gets put into these very situations
who has to have these real human emotions.
Right?
And so that,
that's an interesting part and I kind of want without kind of split it is,
and it's a little tough when we're big.
We're very proud of that scene too.
And it does kind of plum,
uh,
some,
some of the darker depths of this particular character.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
it was one of those scenes that,
as we animated it,
we were,
we kept,
we kept shifting things like,
and we would,
it,
it came across in the animation we thought,
Oh man,
this is really powerful.
And then when it came time to score it and mix it,
we found that taking out the sound effects and just letting the score play
actually really made it land emotionally.
So it was one of those,
it kind of kept evolving throughout our process.
Yeah.
I think that,
um,
the idea that hero inherits his brothers robot and then wants to turn them into
something other than what it was intended to be a is actually a lot of the fun
and the comedy of the movie,
but we knew inevitably will lead to a terrible choice.
And we knew it wouldn't be true to not do that.
And,
and,
but it is a challenge.
We were asking the audience to suddenly sever from their main character and not
like what he was doing.
Uh,
but,
but we knew it had to be in the film.
And so I,
we,
we took it on and hopefully we did it.
Well.
I think that was the,
that was a great thing is it was completely unexpected.
Yeah.
And it's a testament to you two guys to don and Chris.
I mean,
I think there's some really brave film making going on.
Uh,
you know,
the fact that they,
oh Gosh,
say,
uh,
the fact that they do not depend on sound effects,
they do not depend on a score.
They actually let moments go silent,
you know,
which I think in animation is really important because it is a visual art form
and they really play into the strengths of animation and also the power of
emotion and not try and gimmick it up.
And that's youtube guys.
You're great.
Thanks Roy.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
Was there a lot of pressure because you know,
Disney is kind of in this new golden age of animation again,
kind of back in the 90s when I was little mermaid and Aladdin and being the
beast,
and now you have tangled,
which was just an amazing film and you wreck it Ralph and frozen,
you know,
is there a lot of pressure to succeed?
Like after frozen comes out?
It does last year come in and like,
oh my gosh,
we need a valid with Baymax,
you know,
singing oh yeah.
With the cigar and the old?
Uh,
no,
no.
Um,
I mean the pressure is really more internal than external to be honest with you.
And,
and the fact that we grew up Disney fans,
our whole building is full of fans and,
and some somewhere in their childhood,
they were emotionally touched by a Disney film and that made them want to work
there.
Right.
And so the pressure is strictly can we make a film that is a Disney film but as
fresh and new and can it sit on the shelf with those other,
you know,
classics.
And so really it was more of an internal pressure than any kind of external
pressure.
We don't compete with other Disney movies in that way.
We were actually a pretty small community at,
at Disney animation,
and we all work on each other's movies.
And so anyone movie's success is everyone's success.
And so yeah,
we were not worried about trying to make more money than frozen.
There was no such thing as more money than frozen,
all of them.
But,
but what is important,
we have a relationship with the audience.
You know,
they track Disney feature animated films and we want them to believe that if
they come to see one of our movies,
whatever the genre we're taking on,
that they'll have a great experience.
That's what's most important.
And that's the thing that Kinda keeps me up at night.
I think the strength of the studio right now is the fact that,
you know,
dawn was working on Winnie the Pooh and decided he wanted to do a superhero
movie that split,
you know,
for me,
I'd done tangled and the next thing I do as a superhero movie.
That's great.
And that's,
that's the strength of our studio right now in terms of storytelling.
And it's all about the storytelling and,
and whenever we make a choice,
it's about what's the best story.
Yeah.
No,
I think that's incredible too.
Uh,
you know,
with you guys as the voice cast and stuff with your guys' costumes,
did you have any say over that stuff?
Any little bits and pieces of it or not really
zero Weintraub though.
So I hope that happens for me.
Cause it absolutely adorable.
Yeah,
it was pretty good.
And I want to talk a little bit about that with the costumes and their and their
powers and everything.
Cause you know,
you had,
you know,
Wasabi,
he has basically lightsaber hands is essentially what he has a,
Fred has a,
is a fire breathing monster,
you know,
Bay Max has his karate skills and Gogo has the,
wheel discs.
Honey has the purse bombs and purse.
Not Terrible.
Right.
I like it.
Some balls we called scream then to respond.
But the incredible thing with hero is that actually he doesn't have anything.
He just has this suit and Baymax and he needs Baymax and,
but that was very particular and very specific to your character where it was,
you're kind of nothing without but not nothing,
but you're not,
you need baymax.
Yeah.
It's funny you go,
you go all the way back to kind of the origin and big hero six and you see
hero's role and it's still very much the same thing from the comic book till the
film.
He is,
he is the strategist.
He is the guy who figures out the plan.
Um,
and he's the guy that,
you know,
um,
he's basically like it these guys form like Voltron and I'm stealing a line from
the Wu Tang clan hero is the head.
Um,
and,
uh,
yeah,
you know,
he doesn't have any,
he doesn't,
he didn't,
he didn't add anything to a suit except for the fact that he connects to Bay
Max.
Um,
and yeah,
I mean,
you,
when you watch the film,
you hear him kind of call out,
oh,
do this,
do that.
And,
um,
it,
it's great because everyone's powers could,
they come together really nicely and everyone's skills and,
um,
their intellect come together in a way that they can work together as a team
really well
is important.
Uh,
early on,
you know,
when we first started developing it,
that,
um,
I just made a choice to not have super beings in this movie.
Um,
I felt like there was
a lot of that.
And,
uh,
I liked the challenge of creating the,
really the superpower in the movie is their intelligence.
It's super tech really,
and the,
and the smarts of the,
of these characters.
And,
and,
uh,
it,
it led us down,
you know,
interesting.
Cause it made us research more and boy,
I mean we found,
you know,
so many really cool maglev technology.
We researched that and uh,
you know,
even telekinesis for heroes microbots which we thought was a crazy Scifi kind of
thing.
It turns out that,
you know,
there are people working on some rudimentary aspects of telekinesis.
So like probably us,
right?
Probably Google.
Um,
so,
but uh,
you know,
and I think it paid off and that the,
that they do feel,
you know,
they're,
they're mortal beings.
They're just kids.
They're just call it really go,
goes.
Really the only one that has any business being a superhero to be honest with
you at two carries the team for a while,
carries him a little bit.
But it is a sort of celebration of sort of the maker movement and Super
Technology.
Yeah.
They're all smart.
I mean,
they're all smart kids and we celebrate that and they have a lot of potential.
And that's one of the things the movie talks about is that each of us has
potential.
And what are you going to do with it?
Are you gonna do something selfish or selfless with it?
And if this movie in any way inspire science,
terrific curiosity,
then,
then that's a good thing.
Yeah,
I do want to double back because these guys may not think they had anything to
do with actually the look of their character,
but essentially their performances are what finally shaped the character.
We don't do,
you know,
we,
we don't do anything with the character until we have that voice.
And so,
you know,
slight design changes and you know,
all kinds of things in terms of costume,
it's all a result of your performance and the body language as well.
Absolutely.
You know,
what was kind of the balance of,
you know,
you're taking this very obscure marvel property and try and translating that
into,
you know,
uh,
the guys,
you know,
Disney marvel just did it with gardens and galaxy.
You guys are doing with big hero six kind of introducing this and kind of find
that balance of respecting the original property,
but also making it your own.
And it gets,
you know,
looking back to the original,
because I didn't really know it and I was looking at some of it crosses but
some,
but you know,
some characters are different and I mean Baymax is completely way better than
the original.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
well in,
in,
it actually came from one of the first meeting we have with marvel when we win.
You know,
I pitched several ideas to John based on marvel ideas and he gravitated towards
big hero six and as did the other directors,
you know,
we,
we generally pitch stuff to all the other directors.
We all kind of work on each other's stuff,
you know,
and everybody seemed to gravitate towards the big hero six.
And uh,
uh,
marvel was super cool with it and they just said,
don't worry,
you don't have to worry about setting this in the marvel universe.
You don't have to worry about iron man and captain American.
And everybody showed up,
you know,
they were really encouraged us to make it our own.
And that's what led to San Fran Soko.
If it's not the marvel universe,
which is generally New York City in the,
in the real world,
um,
you know,
then what is our world that led to San Francisco?
And,
and ultimately,
you know,
they were,
they gave us complete freedom to kind of make this our own.
And so we ended up,
you know,
really kind of taking the characters names and we tried to base their tech on
something from the comic book loosely.
Um,
but baymax really Wa is a kind of a whole new character.
And that came from our research.
You know,
I did a robotics tour very early on,
about three and a half years ago actually.
And,
uh,
Harvard,
Mit,
and actually Carnegie Mellon was where I found a researcher named Chris Atkinson
who was doing research in soft robotics.
And you guys are probably working on it too.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
I met Chris Adkisson and,
and,
uh,
you know,
I'd never seen eighth.
I was on the hunt for something unique.
I,
you know,
I knew it was gonna be a challenge to put a,
a unique robot on screen.
We've seen so many,
uh,
and not only that,
but he had to be appealing and huggable everybody kept saying it's gotta be
huggable robot.
So when I saw that soft robotics,
that's when I knew that we'd found our Baymax.
And so his,
his character,
his personality,
everything from Baymax came from that research trip.
And the fact that it stems from a more obscure property is actually really
served us because it meant the audience wasn't going to bring any preconceived
notions about what the character should be,
where the story should be.
It was one thing you can't emphasize enough is how fluid our story environment
is.
We spend years crafting the story and it changes quite a bit over the course of
that journey.
And the whole system is designed to be constantly questioning your assumptions
about the story.
And so it changed dramatically.
So,
you know,
one thing you know is whatever you start out with,
you're going to end up with something else at the end of the journey.
So better to start with something that people don't have a fixed idea of what it
should be.
Interesting for.
You know,
the development of characters.
You kind of brought in that,
you know,
the story is constantly changing and you guys are probably brought in,
I'm guessing several times to do audio now.
Is there any thought to bring it in these actors,
maybe even sooner,
maybe earlier in the process,
kind of when you're developing the characters or you still trust trying to find
them and find their voice,
but would it be easier almost to find the actors first and then kind of develop
the character from there or is that they are part of the process?
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah.
For for you,
for years you guys have been involved,
right?
For a year and a half or so.
Oh,
is that right?
I mean,
yeah,
even when they audition,
I mean we had pages,
but it was kind of like,
okay,
take it and do whatever.
You know?
I really encourage them to bring a lot of themselves to it and bring any kind of
Improv because again,
it keeps it fresh and for us and when they were not,
the characters were definitely not baked.
When when you guys came in,
I mean you had huge impact on defining these characters and yeah,
the,
the
sure we'll be always evolving.
The scenes will be changing.
So you guys will be asked to come in and rerecord the scene over and over and
over again and I've always really impressed by your patients
or we probably didn't.
I am going to use how many recording sessions with you for 15 more than 20 and
they could be four or five hour sessions and it was pretty demanding and you
guys never lost faith,
I felt,
you know what I mean?
Every reason to,
I think because you're seeing scenes change over and over and over again.
Being able to come in so many times I was able to see how the script evolved and
I just thought it was,
he kept going and like I already thought it was phenomenal,
but then it just kept evolving and becoming better and better and better.
And um,
I mean every time,
every time I came in,
it was just,
I was happy to see that I had that it could get better.
I don't know.
It was a weird,
I was like,
it's not going to get any better than this.
And it did.
It's an interesting thing for you because your character isn't most of the
films.
So you saw most of the script because these guys only see really the chunks of
the script that they're in.
And so,
you know,
he was able to see the kind of arc developing.
You guys probably had a little bit more what's going on here.
I'm glad you guys were able to finally settle on an opening.
The film is,
that's always the last thing.
The last thing,
if there were so many versions of the first scene of the movie,
to Roy's point though,
we never read,
I wouldn't say we ever really have a finished script,
you know,
um,
to,
to hand out because,
because of that evolution,
I mean there may be a complete script at one point,
but it's never done in an our terms,
you know?
And so we can't really ever had out of finish group cause it doesn't exist
really until the movie's done.
We keep iterating and iterating and iterating.
And so there's no version of like a shooting script,
you know,
in light of action.
In a sense.
It's the shooting script is like when it's done and it's,
that's the shooting script.
Yeah.
Oh there it is.
There is there all time.
And for you three,
you know,
with,
with anytime you're acting,
you're always a character.
Right.
And so what were kind of your inspirations of trying to bring these characters
to life?
You know,
was it yourself?
Was it a sibling?
Was it another actor?
Was it something from your childhood?
You know,
what was kind of bringing about,
um,
cause obviously you're not,
you know,
14 and you know,
20 year old and so,
you know,
in college,
um,
man,
it's,
it's funny because everyone keeps asking the question,
how are you similar into your character?
And well we,
I don't really have any differences from here other than the fact that he's,
he's much smarter than I am
but,
but certain ways in certain ways.
But besides that,
we're so,
I mean we're so similar and even obviously the body language and you know,
the way you see hero onscreen that's attributed to the animators.
Um,
but I didn't have to change my voice at all for the project.
It's my voice during,
through and what was written on the page.
I feel like things have already gone through things I've already experienced.
Um,
things I've said even.
And,
um,
obviously when I was able to Improv,
I was able to bring more of myself to him.
But honestly,
every time I went in there was nothing I had to do.
All I did was walked through the door.
They started recording,
I read lines off off a page and it was just
was me.
Yeah,
I think you're going to see a parallel because there's a reason why they hired
us.
Thank God.
You know,
so you're going to see some resemblances.
But I feel like for my character,
you know,
they gave me a great direction and it was,
she's,
she's the female version of Clint Eastwood,
you know,
she doesn't have a lot to say,
but when she says it,
it's just straight to the point.
Um,
so that was really helpful.
So what you're saying is you're the easiest job because you only had so crazy.
We had to learn to escape though.
Will,
yeah,
we had to ask her to be mean sometimes.
It was sort of breaking away from who you actually are,
I think more mean for me to get pushy here.
Nastier.
So was there any room for improvisation?
Because you mentioned that,
so you've got to Improv a little bit.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
There's sections where it's a blur because I had so much fun.
I was like,
I can't believe I went and I got paid for it.
All you guys would say,
can I try something?
And the answer is always yes,
always has to be asked because you might get great stuff.
And also you want to see their interpretation of the scene,
the moment,
the character,
and you want to create that environment where where everyone's point of view is
worth listening to.
So yeah,
it was,
you guys offered so much great stuff that was off page.
It's also cool to see it in the final it when it's done,
you go,
oh my line made it like,
you're like,
oh,
no way.
Yes,
they approve.
You know,
Tj,
I'm sure it was just,
I was just constantly,
no,
he's stuck to the script the whole time.
Oh,
there's a
great teacher.
He's a crazy man,
isn't him?
Well Scott,
interestingly enough though,
was probably the most scripted character cause Baymax you know,
he,
we were pretty strict with him and how he is syntax and how he speaks and,
and it was,
it was all very kind of scripted out.
And Scott is such an amazing actor and improper that he could find nuances
within lines to make them funny or actually to make them,
you know,
tug at your heartstrings,
you know?
And,
and that's just testament to how,
you know,
cause we really kind of him to him as far as,
yeah,
he had a very tight envelope with which to act.
But he did a great job.
Yeah.
I was going to ask about it backs because I know Scott's not here,
but his character is,
it's so interesting like his voice and how you,
how do you even find Scott,
because it's gotta be hard to cast the boys cause you're probably going with,
you know,
trying to figure out what's going to be a robot voice.
You know,
we looked at,
yeah,
I looked at several,
lost a few right.
And the 40 ish,
I don't know.
But,
uh,
and,
and you know,
there was a certain,
definitely had something in mind,
you know,
that it had to be that kind of calm,
soothing,
kind of peaceful,
you know,
cheerful tone.
Cause he's a nurse and he,
that's how he views the world.
And,
and,
and so we're really looking for the right tonality.
And then when Scott came in,
he was really good at,
he brought that idea of,
um,
you know,
like when you call a call center and it's not a human being on the other end,
there's always that weird pause in between words.
You know,
Scott brought that in there and it seemed to really fit the character and it,
was there anything that was really just so crazy and wild,
but she really wanted it in the film,
but it just didn't fit or you just got to cut it or,
that's a hard question.
There were scenes the fall,
the villain's plot a little more that were really fun and cinematic but
ultimately didn't serve the stories so they had to go.
Yeah,
you just can't,
you know,
when you're making an animated film,
unlike a live action film,
you know,
there is,
uh,
you know,
we are generally in the 85 to 90 minute range and can't really go too much
beyond that.
Um,
for many reasons actually.
And so it does make you like,
be like,
you have to Sorta kill your babies as far as like,
okay,
does that work?
Does it not?
Does that further the story?
And,
and you gotta be really hardcore,
you know,
a kill your darlings.
We know.
Everybody knows the term.
Right.
It's like,
Whoa,
the family.
Uh,
but,
uh,
so,
you know,
you do have to make those tough choices.
So there were,
yeah,
we did follow the villains story a little bit and they were very cool cinematic
scenes.
But,
um,
I just didn't further heroes emotional story,
which had to be the main story.
So it was there any point where you just got completely stuck and you were just,
this is not going to work cause I know every film baseband and yeah,
birth is just,
it's,
you know,
it's not good.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
we,
we put up a series of screenings,
which are a story reels,
um,
uh,
storyboards with music and dialogue and sound effects.
And,
and we put up,
I think it's seven or eight versions of the story of wheels internally over the
course of making the movie.
And at the,
after every screening,
uh,
you get lots of opinions and lots of ideas not to feedback.
And you're in a position to do lots of soul searching about what you think is
working,
what's not working,
what your vision of the film was,
what it now has to be.
Cause that's constantly evolving as well.
And,
uh,
and there,
there are moments where you think,
well,
I don't know if we can crack this one.
You know,
were we,
this was a very ambitious story plot wise.
And as far as the emotional storyline,
very ambitious.
Um,
and,
and there were certainly moments where we thought,
boy,
I don't know if we're going to be able to crack this one,
but somebody would keep talking,
you know,
so we just keep going and,
and the machine would just keep,
we,
there's about eight or 10 people in that story room,
a sitting across the table from each other,
uh,
for days on end.
At the end.
That process goes for years.
And a,
and somebody will always be that spark plug that fires up the conversation and
keeps it going and,
and we all fire off a of each other.
And so,
um,
there might have been those,
those moments of doubt,
but we're the people that we're surrounded by,
it doesn't take very long.
We're very fortunate in the sense that we have this story trust and it's all the
directors that work on all the films and you know,
we,
we meet after every screening and have these great offsites and,
and,
and discuss,
um,
you know,
specific notes.
But there were two moments that I remember that were really,
uh,
essential.
We did one offsite and we brought in a psychologist and a couple of social
workers to talk about teenage loss.
And that really kind of solidified hero story in our minds that kind of like
took us in the right direction.
And then the other moment was when we discovered that it was really Baymax who
had to drive the story.
He was the one who actually gets the team together.
And once that happened,
then kind of the pieces started falling into place.
That happened around the fourth
screening.
And so then the next,
you know,
four screenings were about getting all the other elements functioning.
Absolutely.
We're going to do some Q and a as well.
Uh,
people wanna start getting up to the microphone,
but you have any questions.
But,
you know,
something I want to talk about too was what was just your guys' favorite part of
the movie?
You know,
I,
there was a few of those and there's a couple parts where,
you know,
Disney socks you in the gut and you just start crying,
and it's just,
it's a,
some heartbreaking moments,
but there's gotta be some,
you know,
the hero seeing stuff,
but what,
what,
you know,
senior reflection.
But you know,
Roy,
we'll kind of start with you and kind of be aligned.
You know,
that scene that I love the most is when they're walking into the a hall for the
showcase and it's there and they're rolling in the microbots in the,
uh,
in the,
little containers.
And it's just,
it's the team,
it's the team together,
just goofing around and talking and trying to pep him up.
And it's so real and it's so gentle and yet,
you know,
it's,
it's a bunch of kids just shooting the breeze,
you know,
and it just,
for that moment,
I see them together for the first time.
I see them as a team,
I see them as friends,
I see them as buttons,
you know,
and it,
it,
it's a kind of a special scene and it's simple or we,
we already touched on it.
I mean,
my favorite thing in the whole film was actually that was that look,
when I look when hero looks into and to the glass and he's basically does what I
do in my everyday life.
Um,
but I,
I,
the opening is a great scene.
Um,
it's just,
it's a lot of fun on the first flight sequence is great.
Just one,
Brian,
you are not listening and then the end and then this and,
and there's just so many great moments that really are okay.
Um,
my favorite scene is when you see the team trying out their deer and perfecting
it with heath cliff.
That's very funny to me.
Your carriage is very sweet in that scene.
Drunk.
Baymax no battery Baymax is probably the funniest things ever.
Yeah.
Whoever.
I would just keep them on low.
Hanging out.
You like the drunk version better?
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Um,
well there there's a couple scenes I actually don't want to talk about too much
because of spoilers and things,
but um,
one scene that,
that I love and it's,
I think it's a credit to the way that we build our stories is after the,
uh,
the first flight seem where heroes riding on Bay Max from the city for the first
time.
There was a very quiet moment where they're sitting on top of wind turbine above
the clouds and,
uh,
and there's,
there's a stillness and a,
and I think a very,
uh,
a good kind of sentimentality to that scene.
And,
uh,
I'm,
I'm very proud of it and it's,
it's a scene that came very late in the game for us.
Um,
it was only after years of,
of,
of all of the story evolving and
working on the structure that we realized that,
that we were,
we were missing something.
We're missing that scene.
And once we had it,
we couldn't imagine how we ever had had a version of the movie without it.
Um,
so I love that scene and I love what it says about our process that it even
exists.
Yeah.
And for me,
the first flight sequences,
uh,
was the near and dear to my heart and it was in every version of every screening
we ever did.
And,
uh,
and it never really integrated until we came up.
It was Jon laster actually that came up with the idea that that Bay Max was
going to kind of go on a dare devil,
uh,
flight through San Francisco in order to boost heroes,
neuro transmitter levels and get them to feel excited.
And uh,
but it also,
to me it was the ultimate,
this movie to me is like either a moments in this film where I'm like eight
years old and I,
and I know how I would feel about watching that in the theater.
And that's one of those scenes where I just know my year old self would go
bananas for it.
So it's my favorite city.
So That's interesting cause I was going to ask about that too.
So there's that scene.
Was it through every iteration?
So we're going to double those.
It didn't work until we came.
John came up with that idea.
Um,
well like if at the end for instance,
the beginning of the film with a Bot fight that was in the first version of a
couple of versions of the film and then kind of went away and meandered back in
and that often happens,
you know,
just because we're trying out stuff and throw it away,
it doesn't work in this context,
but then you pull it back out and now it works in a new context.
So the first flight was in every version slide.
Maybe he just needed the right context.
Yeah,
exactly.
You need it.
The characters and you know,
where are you?
You could probably jump in here too with the technological challenges cause you
have Baymax is something,
I don't think we've really seen it in terms of a character.
No know he's crazy.
You know and I'm sure that character,
it must have been crazy for the animators.
And then you also have,
uh,
the microbots,
which are just this beautiful,
amazing thing of them coming together.
I kind of want to talk about the technological challenges with that and making
that all time.
Well,
you're,
you're hitting two great teams that we have.
One is tech at him.
They,
they basically work after animation and make sure that that vinyl was actually
vinyl.
I mean it is amazing before the folds and how the vinyl moves,
that's all tech anim and that's just an amazing team that we work with.
And then our effects team who came up with so much in,
in this film,
I mean,
you know,
it's kind of interesting.
If you were to take,
um,
San Francisco in the world that we built in this film,
you could fit tangled,
you could fit,
wreck it,
Ralph,
and you could fit frozen into this world.
It was so amazing what we're able to accomplish just in terms of,
you know,
a rendering power in terms of the animation and all the,
the nuance that's there.
It's,
it's brilliant.
Yeah.
It's,
it's visually beautiful.
I mean,
it's just crazy.
And again,
Baymax is just one of those characters I don't think we've ever seen on screen
before.
Now,
you know,
and some of the crazy goal,
we were rendering like 1.1 million hours per night.
We had 50,000 cores running this thing.
I mean it was insane.
He's saying,
you know,
kind of one of the last things is can we kind of wrap it up?
I don't think there's anyone for the Q and a,
but uh,
for,
uh,
the,
you know,
there's a lot of Easter eggs and a lot of heart bags to,
yeah,
I think,
you know,
I kind of want to tell viewers,
I think basically in Fred's room I saw a ton of stuff.
Yeah.
A little bit in heroes.
The big window.
I'm not going to reveal what it is,
but the window,
is that designed after something and Heroes Room?
The round window?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It wasn't done and it looks like a Pokemon ball.
Oh.
I don't know if that's intentional or not.
Or are you talking about in today's she's lab or,
yeah,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
actually,
no.
You know what that was from a research.
Uh,
there is a robotics lab at MIT that I visited that had that kind of turret,
like window can have like the Millennium Falcon.
And so that always stuck in my head and based it on that.
But we can say Pokemon that's built.
There you go.
I only got like a,
there are lots of Easter eggs and we have lots of marvel fans and obviously
people proud of the Disney history yeah.
In our building.
And so they were placing lots of Easter eggs to the point where don and I had to
tell him to knock it off or just too many.
We actually pulled a couple out,
lock it down.
Great.
Um,
I think that's all we have time for because we've got to wrap this up.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Thanks everybody.
Has everybody.
Uh,
the movie comes out,
uh,
Friday,
November 7th,
so just a few days.
And,
uh,
if you guys are going to watch this everything,
make sure you,
you know,
promoted on social media,
g plus Facebook if you're going on a hashtagging,
gets a hashtag big hero six,
the number six.
And uh,
oh,
we have one gift.
And so if you wanna grab that,
Roy,
this is for you guys.
Uh,
you guys had a little bit earlier.
We have a Baymax uh,
android.
So cool.
You guys,
they all sign.
That's going back to the cast and crew of Bay,
a big hero six back and doesn't,
just so that guests for being here.
Appreciate it.
Thank you man.
Thanks everybody.
Okay.